all right blade smith welcome to our
fourth and final event in the summer
forging games now heading into this
after three events here's where things
stand chad obviously you're in the lead
you've got 40 points matt you're
bringing up second place with 21 points
and gary you're pretty far back in the
rear with just seven points however
nobody's out of the running for first
place because heading into this fourth
and final event we gave you guys the
option to earn bonus points by choosing
the difficulty of the weapon that you
forged
chad you chose the nambe nulu worth 20
bonus points tell the judges about the
construction of your blade
i made two billets of 15n20 and 1084
some thulia wood for the handle and two
round glows of african black wood and a
nickel silver palma
all right all right gary you chose the
kaichin dao worth five bonus points
how did it go
i used 5160 for the blade ironwood for
the handle and a brass pommel all right
all right and matt you also chose the
kaichin dao worth five bonus points
i used 13 and 20 1080
the handle is cocobolo and i used some
aluminum for accents in the pommel
all right bladesmiths we are now
entering the performance portion of this
fourth and final event at the end of
this event we're going to be placing you
guys from first through third place
there will be three tests up first the
kill test doug
bladesmiths this is the killing slice
[Music]
now to test the lethality of your weapon
and sharpness i will deliver some
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
and try to slice some sandbags from the
heavens
chad europe first you ready for this yes
sir
the first test is a kill test and i feel
real good going into it i know my
blade's plenty beefy enough that it
should cut right through and not have
any bending or breaking
[Music]
all right yeah let's talk about your
number right here
your spine's very obtuse so a lot of the
weight is very forward on this lending
it to be a forward chopping weapon but
on recovery it takes some effort
but because of that it digs in very deep
into this ballistics dummy as you can
see almost the whole shoulder off your
weapon here sir
will kill
all right gary your turn so you ready
absolutely
i'm nervous i haven't had a first place
in any of the events so i really need
this sword to perform and give me a
chance to win
[Music]
all right gary the balance of this blade
feels good in my hand
the weight of your weapon lets the
weapon do its work i don't have to
control it because i'm not trying to
wield the heavy weapon your edge is very
sharp as you can see there goes one
shoulder overall sir you will kill
all right matt your returns are you
ready yes sir
gary and i made the same weapon that
means that it's going to be head-to-head
basically because the points are the
same on that so it's really going to
come down to whose performs better this
is nerve-wracking
all right matt
catching wow
you're just sharp the bounce that you
have here allows for a deep cut using
momentum as i'm moving there is a little
bit of a glinting on your edge there
chopping through bone
but
the edge is still razor sharp
and it decapitated the head
your weapon sir it will kill
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
i'm gonna take each of your swords
and bash them into these clay pots
skulls
and my favorite the ice block chop
chad you look excited you ready to go
yes sir okay
i know nobody thinks that their blade's
gonna break but if it happens i'm not
gonna get any points and all the
progress that i had made by winning the
first three events is all gonna be for
nothing
[Music]
nice job chad thank you steel held up
great
you still got an edge on there
i don't notice any chips or glinting or
anything
but
handle construction is not my favorite
actually just swinging it that much it
started hurting the palm of my hand
having swelled up here
and tapering back
but you survived good job thank you
hey gary ready to go let's do it
uh
[Music]
nice job gary your head still looks good
no damage at all
the handle is
semi-comfortable could use a little more
refinishing i like the little skull and
crossbone you put on there it's a nice
extra touch
but uh
it's all still tight good job thank you
matt i know you're ready right steal it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right matt you survived but there's
a couple problems you picked up a pretty
significant bend in your blade up here
it's pretty thin coming up into this
area and it was just a bit too much for
it the edge on your blade
is still there
it's not as sharp as it was though
before other than that
survived good job thanks
all right gentlemen the final test the
final event the sharpness test
now we have three different bags up here
three different materials this test is
all about the edge of your blade and
what it does to these targets
chad you're up first you're ready yes
sir
so right off chad it's a beautiful
weapon on the first bag i cut with more
of the head i cut deeply the second bag
there's a section right here
that's not very sharp just didn't cut
into that bag the third bag that cut
really deep
but made it sharp nicely done thank you
all right gary you're up next ready to
go i'm ready
gary you're catching dow it does exactly
what it's supposed to do
it's got a good edge on it cut
beautifully nicely done thank you
all right matt ready for this sure
matt the blade right where it took that
bend
is not very sharp i can run my finger on
it without worrying about it you can see
the cuts are kind of torn it's a ragged
cut as opposed to that clean cut
and on the last bag it barely cut it but
will it cut yes it will
all right gentlemen the judge's
deliberation is complete with 84 points
at the end of this competition is chad
congratulations you are the summer
forging games champion
how about that huh
chad you can come forward and grab your
damascus medal congratulations i am the
fortune fire champion being the champion
means a lot it means that i can turn out
very oddly shaped weapons i feel real
good
gentlemen you all did fantastic work in
our very first summer forging games be
proud of yourselves good job
chad you're leaving with fifteen
thousand dollars all right gary you're
leaving with four thousand dollars and
matt you get it down good job guys
everybody's a winner
it feels really good and i'm happy
what's next for me i'm gonna go home
wait for my money to arrive buy a
grinder and then i'm gonna take my wife
on a date
[Music]
you